[Applause]
there are 26 count them 26 ways to
finish near automata this deceptively
dark vision of Earth 10,000 years into
the future is so treacherous that most
of the game's endings are Downers but if
you stay true to yourself while sticking
to your mission objectives you might
find the game's happier conclusions
specifically the five main endings a
word of warning there are some major
spoilers if you like our tips on games
like Nier automata give us a thumbs up
and subscribe to our channel add your
own ending discoveries to the
conversation below let's get to it
for the first main ending ending a
complete all of two B's main missions
you'll see credits roll and this public
service announcement from Square Enix PR
it's a message that encourages you to
keep playing to see the other endings to
get ending B start a new playthrough
using you're ending a save file simply
play through the main missions to reach
the ending and another set of credits
continue using your save file and play
through the new storyline to reach
ending C the penultimate scene is a
confrontation between a2 and 9s choose
a2 as your character complete the
mission and credits will roll as you
might have guessed choosing night as in
the prior scene will result in ending d
the good news is that you don't have to
replay the entire section leading up to
that branching point now that Stage
Select has been unlocked simply go to
the scene right before the duel and
select 9s compared to what you've
experienced so far ending e is a piece
of cake when the credits roll for ending
D one of your pods will eventually ask
you yes or no question select yes now
there's a challenging shooter section
that follows it gets really tough at the
second half so don't be afraid to ask
for assistance from your fellow near
comrades
and there you go endings a through e if
you're interested in getting the more
throwaway endings we suggest you play
against your good nature like killing
innocent robots or veer away from your
mission parameters if you're still on
the fence about Nier automata check out
our review
thanks for watching
[Music]
Oh